toulon nous allons refermer ce journal
en compagnie d'un grand monsieur du
cirque le clown francine y pendant des
années son duo avec le clown blanc alex
a bercé l'enfance d'une génération de
téléspectateurs qui n'ont sûrement pas
oublié la piste aux étoiles à 68 ans ce
marseillais d'origine a posé ses valises
en bretagne sans oublier sa provence
alex et francine y un duo de clowns dont
l'image est restée longtemps lié à la
célèbre piste aux étoiles
il y a dix ans alex le clown blanc
disparaissait aujourd'hui l'auguste
jacques font signe à 68 ans il est plus
que jamais vivant
la piste aux étoiles ça me rappelle le
bon moment
ah oui ah ben oui bien sûr fabuleux
parce que j'ai eu
on a eu la chance avec alex de de faire
des bisous des toiles avec des avec des
très grands quoi j'étais depuis sous des
toiles et ferment reno qui a pour la
première fois fait le clown
j'ai fait une bise et etoiles avec
martial hamon avec maurice biron avec
jacques fabbri avec jacques esterel même
le couturier a été ouverte et des très
bons moments laventure d'alex et
francine est né dans les années 60 avec
jean nohain aujourd'hui jacques francine
iaddict le morbihan il passe ses fêtes
de fin d'année sur les routes de l'ouest
pour faire rire et chanter petits et
grands avec toujours une certaine
nostalgie de sa provence natale
le marseillais a montagnes ju
méridionale mais j'adore olivier j'adore
mon pays bien sûr parce que bon il ya
une chaleur non seulement par le soleil
mais aussi par le caractère et et puis
l'accent des gens mais disons que j'ai
choisi la bretagne parce que je trouve
que c'est un petit peu plus authentique
il ya une qualité de vie meilleure
bravo
et là ya pas de nouvelles
pourquoi y aurait pas bouclé
c'est un petit peu je sorte 2 de match
de ping pong entre le public et
l'artiste et plus le public renvoie la
balle plus l'artiste aussi la renvoie
aussi aussi pas encore plus fort on crée
un personnage qu'on garde après
pratiquement toujours tout donné est ce
que ça ne paraît pas un petit peu au vu
de certaines personnes un peu désuet
alors qu'on a besoin non je vais vous
dire moi je crois que ça apparaît désuet
aux yeux des des gens métier au
contraire alors que le public normande
d'ailleurs pour preuve quand je fais
encore des spectacles pour les enfants
mais c'est les mêmes qui à 40 ans la
maison avant de faire le pont
j'ai fait quelques années de musicologie
revient un petit peu j'aime bien ce
couteau parce que c'est un petit peu mon
pays aussi je suis je suis né avec
vincent scotto quoi mais sommes pas toi
ces mots là on je crois pression tout
quand je donne mon résultat d'un change
coteaux de plus en plus chez des gens un
peu plus jeunes qui viennent c'est à
dire qu'il ya des gens 40 ans 35 ans
pirro des coûts qui découvre ça et qui
sont émerveillés par cette musique et
par cette canicule parole vous aimez
l'aspect chaleureux du clown et du
chanteur jeu que l'on retrouve dans les
loges avaient cessé c'est quoi c'est une
merveille le monde biblique c'est ça une
fois qu'on est là sur la scène hippique
on voit tous ces gens ils sont heureux
bas et est ce qu'il ya de meilleur
quel bonheur ça paraît